[Musik]
in dieser geschichte geht es um einen
jungen mann der einen gleichaltrigen
umgebracht haben soll
er wurde rechtskräftig verurteilt wegen
fahrlässiger tötung und schwerer
körperverletzung
egal was sie macht wirklich - otto und
ps 2 keyboard eine interessante firma
peri weise das nächste programm
verbieten
die tragödie beginnt in der nacht vom 21
juli 2007 marcel m damals 20 jahre alt
fährt mit kollegen vom kanton solothurn
richtung aargau
[Musik]
im euro-club kettenbrücke feiern sie
einen geburtstag ebenfalls anwesend der
19-jährige nicky hoheisel das spätere
opfer laut gericht verhält sich hoheisel
gegenüber anderen gästen aggressiv bzw
provokant und sechs einzel und seine
kollegen werden von der security an die
frische luft gesetzt
als marcel m und seine kollegen nach
hause gehen wollen
treffen die beiden gruppen draußen
wieder aufeinander
marcel m wird von seinen kollegen
angestachelt er dürfe sich das anrempeln
ich gefallen lassen nun sollen nun etwas
unternehmen
und richtig los marcel m und horizon
schubsen sich gegenseitig wer angefangen
hat ist nicht ganz klar
die auseinandersetzung dauert nur wenige
minuten
wenn sie sich bereit dass das land die
fatale konsequenz waren sie einfach so
schläge austeilen
aus dieser seite gekommen so translator
sich nicht auf ein youtube leid wenn sie
ein fuß gesetzt und wenn man immer dass
das schlimm ich folge ja ich weiß das
ist bloße begriffe professoren chance
kurz vorstellen
sogar dann muss es ja gut wir dem klo
für sie ob das eine stellt mit einem
achten wenn ich nett aber das dass sie
blaue auge nase brüche oder krise mit
verursacht
das an sich ist ja das nächste rennen
laufen und das hat sich aufgenommen
da der nutzer bereit und aufgenommen als
die security eingreifen flüchten marcel
m und seine kollegen richtung solothurn
auf dem parkplatz der autobahnraststätte
kölliken nord stoppen sie
haben sie sich gefühlt dann sie sich
gegenseitig großen clubs seit der name
jetzt zeigt jost thoma abläufe und salat
oder so das adrenalin und die personen
und 620 und das alles gut gemacht eine
haben jetzt zeigt er gut gemacht dass es
weder von verletzten und das wichtigste
sei noch gar keine gedanken gemacht das
finde ich dabei bis heute passiert so
schlimm ich folge meinen ihr
gesellschaftspolitisches gar keine
gedanken gemacht
tatsache ist nicky hoheisel bleibt
bewusstlos und schwer verletzt am boden
liegen die ambulanz ist schnell vor ort
eisel wird mit einer hirnblutung ins
kantonsspital eingeliefert seine mutter
wird informiert seinem gleichnamigen
wollte ich mich da mikati notfall
ich habe gewartet und noch eine sind
seit wochen wurde niki im spital
kampfspiel bewusst sind seht euch so
viel passiert jedem moment der tragödie
nach zwei monaten stirbt nie gewesen
was hat sich heute von ihrem sohn
gegenüber sitzen nach wie vor vermisst
jede sekunde eine kleine weht und die
dem gedanken machen was an einem punkt
waren jetzt ist im laden hatte jetzt
panik weil ich früher war jetzt im
studio
was hat es auch entscheiden will
das scheidet somit sie fragt sie ihn
begleiten und beobachten was ist
hingegen das ist für mich ein großes
privileg sei dankbar dafür dass zwar
einfach haben einfach das
in dem rückgang könne mache mich aus
weil es im lager da nicht das mir ganz
wichtig
in jener nacht eine mütze und wie nach
dem schlag gegen eine zeltstadt mehr
weiß die kantonspolizei aargau nicht hat
sie die schläger in u-haft setzt vor
allem ist offen wer hoheisel geschlagen
hat der verdacht fällt zunächst auf den
thai boxer bono es in seiner ersten
einvernahme legte nämlich unwissentlich
ein geständnis ab ich habe nur einen mit
der flachen hand im gesicht weggestoßen
beschreiben sie diese person
er hatte eine mütze auf
[Musik]
peres die person will ich um viel viel
rückwärts an eine zeltstadt
was sagen sie dazu
[Musik]
es trifft zu dass die person rücklings
an eine zeltstangen fiel die person
stand aber wieder auf rs die person die
sie schlugen und die eine mütze trug war
nicky hoheisel
er fiel rücklings um und schlug mit dem
kopf an einer stange an der schluss des
polizisten drängt sich auf zwei boxer
bono es sagt aus er habe einen mit einer
mütze geschlagen der gegen eine
zeltstangen gefallen sei und das trifft
nur auf nicky hoheisel zu der fall
scheint klar
zurück in seiner zelle muss bono es klar
geworden sein dass er nun der
hauptverdächtige ist um plötzlich tönt
alles ganz anders
ab jetzt ist marcel m an allem schuld
sehen wir die kollegen anscheinend vor
25 jahren das einer panne kann ich
glaube dass deshalb sage ich mir dass
meine taktik vor
das ist keine verhört taktik ist merkt
marcel m erst an der sogenannten
konfrontation einvernahme anwesend sind
marcel m bruno s und die anwältin von
bono es der seinen kollegen tatsächlich
schwer belastet hat nachdem sie marcel
anfänglich deckten gaben sie in der
letzten einvernahme an dass sie gesehen
hätten wie marcel auf eine am boden
liegende person mit fäusten und mit
fußtritten eingeprügelt hatte
ich bestätige dass nach wie vor
peres ebenso gaben sie an der erste den
marcel vor sich hatte dem gab masse ohne
zu zögern eine faust ins gesicht
er prügelte dann weiter auf ihn ein dann
fiel er um dürfte wohl an eine zeltstadt
gefallen sein
das habe ich genau so wahrgenommen
marcel m sagt zunächst ich kann nur
sagen dass ich nie wirklich nur
geschubst hatte dann plötzlich ich kann
mich nicht mehr richtig erinnern
die
bruno s beteuert ich war nie in der nähe
dieses niki der einzige der richtig
geprügelt hat war marcel marcel m
resigniert ich denke ich bin schuld das
war alles meine schuld ich habe ja
schließlich angefangen
damit verschwindet thaiboxer bruno es
aus dem fokus der ermittler
er bekommt lediglich eine busse wegen
raufhandels
marcel m dagegen muss sich 2009 vor dem
bezirksgericht aarau für nicky hoheisel
tod verantworten
[Musik]
das öffentliche interesse ist riesig die
verhandlung wird vom engen
bezirksgericht ins geräumige kongress
zentrum verlegt
[Musik]
es ist einer der emotionalsten prozesse
der jüngeren geschichte
[Musik]
gerichtspräsident thomas müller leitet
die verhandlung zentral ist die frage ob
der tod zweifel zwei die folge eines
schlages war ein gutachten soll dies
klären
das gutachten vergünstigung für
rechtsmedizin der universität bern hat
der große rolle spielt dass insbesondere
nachdem klar wurde nicht dass der antrag
die die kausalität zwischen umschlag
untermieter tod bestritten und genau für
das sind fachleute die die professorin
vom institut für rechtsmedizin wieso
nicht die frage in ständiger praxis
immer wieder entscheidet und das
gutachten zeigt dass das eine sehr
spezielle wissenschaft ist die
schlussfolgerung von einem gutachter
sind dorthin chance das sind hier so
ausgelösten trächtige oktober klar ist
hoheisel hat ein sogenanntes aneurysma
im gehirn ein aneurysma sieht aus wie
ein ballon und ist eine
lebensgefährliche aussackung einer
arterie platzt ein solches aneurysma
kommt es zur herrn blutung entscheidend
ist im vorliegenden fall ob das
aneurysma vor bestehend war oder sich
als folge eines schlagers bildete das
gutachten ist unmissverständlich an der
kausalen verknüpfung zwischen der
schlägerei und dem tod sei nicht zu
zweifeln
nun geht es nur noch um die frage ob ihn
jene nach zweifelsfrei marcel m den
fatalen schlag ausgeführt hat der
hoheisel vor der kettenbrücke traf das
gericht befindet dass die den
angeklagten belastenden aussagen im kern
übereinstimmen
es gebe keine zweifel marcel sei
schuldig der fahrlässigen tötung der
schweren körperverletzung und des
raufhandels
er wird zu einer freiheitsstrafe von
fünf jahren verurteilt
logistik assistent marcel m der bis
dahin nie als gewalttätig aufgefallen
war verlässt das gericht als
erstinstanzlich verurteilte totschläger
[Musik]
am nächsten tage hält sein beteilige
diesen brief darin heißt es der tod von
nicky hoheisel sei nicht auf eine
verletzung zurückzuführen sondern die
folge eines vor bestehenden hirn
aneurysma es gewesen zwischen der
schlägerei und der todesursache bestehe
also keine kausalität
unterzeichnet ist der brief von hwf
andino chefarzt am kantonsspital aarau
er sei von der einlieferung bis zum tod
federführend gewesen basels behandlung
sagt von dino dass der tod die folge
eines schlages sein soll habe er mit
verwunderung aus der zeitung erfahren
der patient lag bei uns zwei monate weil
viele leute involviert ersten radiologen
neurologen neurochirurgen neurologen und
keine von uns kein behälters oder evo
wird die person wurde befragt sie haben
sich ja dann mit einem brief zuerst
telefonisch und mit einem brief dann an
den gerichtspräsidenten gewendet wieso
haben sie das gemacht weil ich dachte
aber wir dachten die wirkung bei schon
dass die befunde und die beurteilungen
mangelhaft waren für das gutachten
standen unterlagen aus raum zur
verfügung wie so die interpretation
dieser unterlagen aus seiner sicht
mangelhaft ist davon die nur dem gericht
nicht erklären
der strafprozess ich sehe detailliert
abgefasst und verpflichtete richtung
partei ist sehr knapp da zahlt und
strafprozess ohne zeit wenn
beweisaufnahme abgeschlossen issues
letzte woche vom 8 denken sie jetzt das
gerichtsurteil politik zurück das ist
genau so passiert und weil naturgemäß
ohne die zwei minuten in tempe urteile
sondern die us piloten geschlagen
genannte touch und und genau wie der
ried ist noch eher von der großkanzlei
mitteilt wurde sie ganz das wichtigste
kommt gleich zu belangen ist unbedingt
sofort telephone co ich bin aus telefon
gegangen und haben sofort gemerkt dass
das ein muster stehen die person ist wo
will in irgendeiner form oft so teil
floss und das ist nichts neues sie
christoph bautz us-seite was für formen
und so weiter könnte bewies real werden
und abgewertet und während das benötigt
es das nicht denn das persönlich ein
telefon
der drv antino erklärt und gesagt jetzt
unter dem umstand könnte ich auf die
aussage vor ihm überhaupt nicht ich habe
man kann einmal eine frage stellt sich
einfach zeit
im dem verfahren geht es einfach keine
energie und euphorie frust sei wurde
nächsten instanz aber sehr wohl
bezirksrichter müller verweist auf das
obergericht des kantons aargau marcel m
's anwalt legt von dinos brief dort vor
und will so ein obergutachten erzwingen
ein privatgutachten holt er nicht ein
problem in dem zusammenhang hängt ist
das private stellt die gutachterstelle
partei das heißt auch ständiges
perfektes gutachten musste sich von
anderen präsentieren damit sicher
gesehen dass das zu einem ergebnis
geführt und zwar kostenfrei
das obergericht beschließt der antrag
des angeklagten auf einholung eines
neuen gutachtens wird abgewiesen
entgegen der meinung des angeklagten
könne keine rede von einem mangelhaften
oder widersprüchliche gutachten seien
[Musik]
für marcel m hieß es inzwischen knast
kleider fassen denn nach dem obergericht
hat auch das bundesgericht entschieden
dass es kein zusätzliches gutachten
brauche das urteil gegen marcel m wurde
rechtskräftig einziger erfolg aus seiner
sicht die strafe wurde auf vier jahre
reduziert darstellte das getan hat das
zeug eines wie vor bietet das verstehe
überhaupt nicht
marcel m verbüßt seine haft in pavillons
einer offenen strafanstalt im kanton
luzern
obwohl laut fachleuten noch viele fragen
offen sind betreffend gutachten erstes
beispiel für die gutachter handelt es
sich eindeutig um eine trauma folge beim
aneurysma also um die folge eines
schlages
grund zunächst war die entsprechende
hirnschlag arterie noch intakt und
nirgends ausgesagt
um es ganz einfach zu sagen die ersten
bilder der gefäße zeigten noch kein
anderes paar später war eines zu sehen
daraus schließen die gutachter es war
nicht vor bestehend sondern entstand
erst später als folge des schlagers laut
van dino ist dieser schluss nicht
zulässig es handle sich vielmehr um ein
phänomen dem er im klinischen alltag
immer wieder begegne kann man gerade
danach nach der wird und nicht
verstellen
weil teil passiert sind und ihr verlauf
können sichtbar werden
reporter bietet professor peter beikost
einen der renommiertesten neurochirurgen
europas und seine expertise bei kurs
leitet die neurochirurgische klinik der
charité in berlin
er bestätigt von dinos einfache mögliche
erklärung
aneurysmen können in der tat bei der
erstdiagnose nicht zur darstellung
kommen die berner pathologen
argumentieren weiter eine allfällige
schwächung des gefäßes durch einen vor
bestehenden krankheitsprozess sei sehr
unwahrscheinlich da die übrigen hirn
basis schlagadern unauffällig gewesen
sein
mit anderen worten weil die anderen
gefäße in ordnung waren können das
aneurysma nicht vor bestehend gewesen
sein
andino widerspricht es gebe schlicht
keinen zusammenhang
die meisten patienten die ich je
gefahren haben auch gesunde gefäße
reporter kontaktiert professor engelbert
knosp einen weiteren europäischen
spitzenmediziner knosp leitet die
neurochirurgische uniklinik in wien er
stimmt von dino zu der behauptete
zusammenhang existiert schlicht nicht
ich tue mich schwer hier den sinn zu
erkennen üblicherweise sind andere
gefäße ganz normal und unauffällig
[Musik]
[Applaus]
marcel m nützen diese
expertendiskussionen wenig er wird die
kommenden jahre als schweine knecht
verbringen und als verurteilter
totschläger obwohl es laut experten
starke indizien gibt die gegen die
kausalität zwischen schlag und tod
sprechen
das aneurysma war nämlich in der so
genannten big das ist die hintere untere
kleinhirn arterie damit sich dort ein
aneurysma als folge eines schlages
bildet bräuchte es laut experten größte
gewalteinwirkung
[Musik]
traumatische aneurysmen in der pk würden
eine massive nicht übersehbare schwere
schädelbasis faktor beinhalten im
rechtsmedizinischen gutachten heißt es
allerdings bei der obduktion seien keine
kopfverletzungen festgestellt worden
klar ist indes in jener nacht lied
hoheisel eine hirnblutungen und blieb
nach der auseinandersetzung bewusstlos
liegen
war das dann ein zufall dass gerade in
diesem moment es zu einer hirnblutung
kaum kann sein kann sei es gibt viele
blutungen spontane blutungen die so
passieren können
was sind denn dinge die das begünstigt
das so zum beispiel der hohe blutdruck
bei einer solchen auseinandersetzungen
oder was sind andere fachkräfte genau
solche situationen kann natürlich eine
helle aufregung
druck werde blutungen führen
mir scheint es dass das aneurysma hier
eher spontan entstanden um nicht trauma
folge ist der verantwortliche gutachter
ulrich zollinger kam zum gegenteiligen
schluss
heute ist solinger emeritiert und als
selbständiger gutachter tätig er stehe
zum gutachten schreibt der reporter
detail fragen beantworte er aber nicht
in den medien sondern höchstens vor
einem gericht weiter das gutachten wurde
vor gericht durch andere experten die
bei der verfassung nicht mitgewirkt
hatten bestätigt und bis vor
bundesgericht nie durch ein
obergutachten bezweifelt marcel m hofft
dass endlich ein solches ober gutachten
in auftrag gegeben und noch einmal
untersucht wird ob wirklich der schlag
zum tod führte
wirkliches gefühl dass das urteil taxi
irgendeinem revidiert wird
aber das gefährt sie das auch schon
angestoßen
ich mag meint ja jetzt mir das einfach
kopiert das ist keine fixe gar nicht
und so endet diese geschichte mit der
frage hat marcel m wirklich getötet
[Musik]
[Applaus]
einfach mail ich freue mich dass führen
herrgott lag so bis zur diesmal mit dem
erfinder stefan heuß uns als talk-gast
oswald grübel ceo der ubs
jacobo müller klar
[Musik]
entweder gerade wie es diese
geheimrezept oder ich esse eure käse nie
wieder bin ich klar das rezept seines
geschmacks bleibt geheim
appenzeller würzigen käse der schweiz
weißt du wo er kinder überraschung kommt
hmm
alles beginnt in der abteilung für
spannung
gefolgt von den abteilungen für spiel
und schokolade
zusammen bilden sie die perfekte
kombination für ein ganz besonderes sei
kinder überraschung gemacht um die welt
zu überraschen
der neue abt